in the weeks and months ahead we will
make the positive case for independence
will the opposition if they can
make the case for continued westminster
rule
[Music]
minister thank my honorable gentleman
it's always good to see him in his place
no no genuinely it's good to see him in
his place it's not the right time for
another referendum given the challenges
that we face as one united kingdom and i
think and he referred to some of the
challenges in scotland but i think
actually the people of scotland want
their two governments to work together
and we are
keen willing enthusiastic to do so
ian blackfoot there is no case for the
union as we've just heard from the
deputy prime minister because
mr speaker the harsh reality is that the
tories might fear democratic debate but
they don't have the right to block
scottish democracy
as the late
canon kenyan right said what if the
other voice we all know so well responds
by saying
we say no
we are the state
his answer
will we say yes
and we are the people
just last year
the member for murray
the leader of the scottish conservatives
no less put it in his own words
a vote for the scottish national party
is another vote for an independent
referendum
you won't often hear me say this but i
agree with him and so do the scottish
people
scottish democracy will not be a
prisoner of any prime minister in this
place
so why is the uk government scared of
democracy or is it simply is it simply
that they have run out of ideas to
defend the failing westminster system
every prime minister i thank the
honourable gentleman i think he's rather
airbrushing history with that long
soliloquy but look he wrench mentioned
the problems that scotland faces a huge
tax burden imposed by the smp
the the scotland's record on science and
maths
under the international pisa rankings
are now uh have dropped below england
and wales and the smp have presided the
worst drug death rate in europe the
highest since records began i think the
people of scotland expect their
government in hollywood and in
westminster to work together to tackle
the issues facing them in their
day-to-day lives